those were our best attacks and they did
nothing we can't beat robotnik as long
as he's got that emerald he's too
powerful look we aren't strong enough to
beat robotnik on our own but there's
three of us your strength your smarts
and my speed together that's how we win
so we make our stand here on the field
of battle as a team
this is it
this is our moment
time to fight
[Music]
bad time to say this but i don't
actually have a plan
tails any ideas
we have to find his weak spot i suggest
the groin what no no no traditionally
yes the groin is the weakest spot stop
by saying groin
look out
i know what his weak spot is it's me i'm
the groin
think about island rent free in this 210
so i go out there and rile them up he'll
focus on only you leaving himself open
to a flanking maneuver from me and the
[ __ ] hedgehog you are a brave and noble
warrior go to your certain death with
honor we're gonna have to work on your
pep talks pal
yeah let's go
all right mustache you want me
come and get me
you don't tell me about coming and
getting i am on the cutting edge i'm
coming and getting comments
coming getting coming getting
oh you're really heavy that's because i
have one million percent muscle
faster fox
let's go
go go go go go keep going go no no no no
no no no no no no whoa what the heck
happened here
are you thinking what i'm thinking let's
go get our kid
we need your truck